okay four people joining this live
stream we are what in what I hope is the
final final stretch of database
integration for version 12 of language
and we are looking at some documentation
of various symbols okay so let's look at
the guide pages first so this is so we
think we finished these guide pages is
that correct yes the ones you have in
your peril are the new symbols okay all
right fine all right let's start at the
top database reference so did I write
these or did they were they written not
by me at all this you wrote but you
already changed them so should be pretty
much fine the one that ended entity
class you haven't looked at much okay
all right okay so this here
and that we never say it this way
you
what no look listen if this is being
presented this way that then the dummy
elements here should be in italics okay
you get what I'm saying so yeah it was
in italic before and then you said it
should look like literal input no no no
the the part of it that is literal input
should look like a literal input okay I
mean they're ever everything you
explicitly type should be in literal
input style everything that you don't I
can make that change okay so so where
are you telling people what the possible
settings for back-end are I'm not not
here I guess okay we need to do that so
let's okay we got a rush forward a
little bit so we really want to call it
back end
I would think so because in this context
it's really in the back and Tallaght
well then but you just say dialect in
the description no it's not the dialect
here it's the back hand here okay but
you say dialect so you don't mean that
okay possible elements so do you
typically have to specify all of these
for all of them yes except for SQLite
that doesn't use a server this is just a
file okay well also imported is often
the default port so poor it is not or
what is the default port it depends on
the database since so in this table
should we give uhm typical elements in a
sock so hold on a second
where do you give the options if you've
given this URL how do you then give the
username and password with that
specification first recent message I
don't understand so so wait a minute
these are ones without passwords when
you just give the URL what's that kept
you're getting called the password
unique URL I see but so one of the
things we're planning ok what about an
authentication option for database
reference so we looked into that and
it's the stuff that we would need which
is keychain will not make it in 12 well
but you could people are gonna burn
their passwords in anyway so you might
as well it's not keychain keychain is to
hide the passwords but if you're
prepared to burn them in you can just
say database reference or dedication
arrow blah you see what I'm saying yeah
and that's what we should support we
should support that I think ok ok umm ok
represents a reference to a local file
based SQL database represents a
reference to a remote SQL ok so then
let's say database reference well does
it I don't know whether this is correct
I'm gonna put this in has the option of
antic ation
which I'm going to future eyes this
which can be used to specify username
and password information
for a remote database well I'm just
gonna blue tries this for now
okay should figure out what to do that
um and database typical elements
and took up all the elements of our Sauk
include okay then we're gonna give more
detail here about what to do okay so I
really do not like the term back-end
unless you unless you're saying the the
type of SQL back-end
used and examples are what
so sqlite okay Postgres so let's say
possible values for the four back-end
include quotes what as fear light yeah
but I I don't know if it's camelcase
like that okay tell me how to tell me
how to type these because I want to know
what the actual strings are here yeah
they lowercased which SQLite and the
others okay so it's like this is that
right is that should also be small no no
we don't do it that way these are our
names right did you get what I'm saying
these are our names so we get to specify
how these get written no I was exactly
correct with my capitalization excuse me
are you sure yes I'm lucky and it's
bringing home page
strange
I'm sure it's like there it is there's a
ton page yes there the names are like
that
so you would you like the names to be
exactly matching the names okay tell me
yes I think now but Steven there is one
thing is that which is confusing which
is when you type it in as as a URL with
back-end as the protocol
even if HTTP is I mean we don't usually
write HTTP or caps in a URL you know
what this should be our controller
matching lower case in any case yeah
okay fine okay but the autocomplete
should be for this and make sure there
is an autocomplete right okay in that
Association the type of SQL back okay
what are the other ones
Postgres how's that do I have all type
is it possible SQL return them know it
is it supposed to kress
okay you guys are gonna give me a list
of what's here okay okay
MySQL no no no just put it in the chat
okay type it and put it in the chat
meanwhile I'm gonna go on with other
stuff okay okay so where does the name
of the database show up oh it's there
right it's under that name field there
um
the name of the database
name of the database or the path to it
again I'm going to explain that
okay the host the internet host is that
right what what is the
what does host mean here can it be the
name of a single um can be a single
machine name or what can it be it's a
server so basically it can be either you
know localhost or IP address or it can
also be the usual like DNS name of the
server if it's over the Internet
because it can also be a local machine
or a network
I've come to make sure we support also
Microsoft spelled out or just mssql as
MS doesn't sound very official okay so
okay I'm not gonna go in and do the
details here of correctly fortifying
these things I'm gonna let somebody else
do that okay okay all right so let's
keep going down here okay the name of
the database our path to it the host
the hosts serving the database actually
a remote database is probably wrong
because it can also be in the same
machine okay well so what is host mean
and they're on the same machine is lost
which is typically a one 27001 you know
yeah yeah right
maybe instead of remote who you should
say server based I I didn't say anything
I said the host no it's promoting their
seventy's it message okay represents
what interesting probably server based
right yeah okay okay so the host serving
the database the port
the server port through which the
database is accessed should we put a
parenthesis that if if if it's the
default of for that specific back-end it
doesn't need to be specified
well I'm we could put a default column
here but I think let's not do that
used foot used the user name used to
authenticate the database it's not
necessarily a remote database right yeah
it can be on the same machine okay okay
so possible values for back-end include
um
possible values for name okay for for
file based databases
such as SQLite name gives the path to
the file containing the database correct
for server-based
you
databases your types served thank you
how you hungry no I'm actually not there
for server based databases name okay so
now you've told me the solar
possibilities could be an IP address
no that's host:look and it was so
basically when you have a remote
database a single database endpoint with
the same password can contain multiple
databases so what me okay Oh
tells you which server and gives you
gives the name of the database at at a
particular what should we say at the
specified endpoint yeah I guess that's
fine um okay the value for host for
value for file based databases no value
need to be specified no values need be
specified for a host and port for server
based databases
um host can be given as a URL string or
as a street is correct because it's not
it's you cannot have a path you cannot
have I mean it's just a horse 3d so it
can be an IP address or a name the host
okay but with the tenant and that host
isn't it yeah yeah yeah but URL okay
fine fine fine as a given host can be
host gives can be an Internet host name
can be a domain name can be an internet
host name or an IP address specified in
a string double-teams will not put the
network instead of Internet because it
look very often being the same local
network okay so that's why the as a with
a string or using an IP address object
right I don't know if we implemented IP
address but we'll fix that
okay
each type of back-end um let's see the
value for the default value for port if
port is not specified the default value
will be used for each type of back-end
no value for port I so far they default
for each type of back-end will be used
okay I think that's about it for that
table do you agree yeah
um gives information about the database
being referenced
you
you
the property prop
can be
so you'd give automatic in the case
where or you would be missing not not
needed in the case where you'd ask for a
host for a file back database is that
correct
you'd give some kind of missing not
needed or something or not available
what do you do I have to check because
they do you remember
sorry when we do all what if you asked
for the port for a file back database
what do you get
in this case yeah yeah you get none okay
because the default oh that's fine it's
fine fine
okay bubbly prop can be
any of the elements okay so this point
okay that point needs to be much higher
up than this
it represents a connection to a database
it does not
a potential connection to a database
symbolically represents how a database
should be symbolically represents
okay wait a minute includes information
on how to
act to a database but does not actually
perform the connection
you
what does perform the connection
calling database reference or connect
why do you talk about relational
database does the connection doesn't
this so if you wrap relational database
around a the miss references will
perform a connection to inspect it and
enclose it otherwise you can explicitly
call connect as property what what
that's not what this says it says it
represents a reference to a database it
doesn't say that some random string
property of it is going to cause some
state to change it's the last detail I'm
understanding but it's not right it's
not the right design
it's not at all the right design we went
through this before we went through this
before remember
okay that is not the right design we
cannot do it this way
this is a symbolic object that
represents a database reference it
doesn't represent it doesn't have if we
need then we should have a thing called
database connect that does that I mean I
don't think the database connect is very
useful probably database disconnect can
be useful in emergencies because for
whatever reason the process is talking
to the database dies in some weird way
oh yeah wait a second wait wait wait
wait I'm listening are you expecting
that anybody who uses database is going
to use database reference brackets
connect no no you you 99% of the time
you don't need any of that but imagine
you are connected because you performing
a query and then your machine dies no no
I'm not asking about that how do you use
this so if you would say relational
database of database reference and that
corresponds to the relational database
is that correct yeah that that will
inspect the database by connecting to it
get information on the schema and then
close the connection no and what happens
in other cases if I want to get entity
value of whatever yeah I could do the
same thing you ever you have a
connection that gets open for the time
you need to perform in the query and
then it gets closed but if for whatever
reason the your connection goes down I'm
not interested I'm interested in a
different thing they having saying
connect here lately useless Connect is
completely useless because all these
operations that you perform on the
database perform a connection
automatically and should disconnect if
anything gets garbage collected properly
but if your machine dies completely in
the middle of a query we cannot
guarantee that it closed it will
probably also when you when you are
finished doing something like at the end
of the script it's a good practice to
lose it
it should auto close well it will auto
close if you in together yes
if you don't quit the gardener it won't
close what are you talking about I
thought you just told me it opens it
does the query I thought so to recover
that it opened the closet no I will be
[Music]
okay so let's get it straight please
does it close it or does it not close it
no it does not okay so then we can every
week and have option to end all those
things but by default I don't think you
should be closing it every time you
you're performing a query oh gosh how
many more rocks are we gonna have to
turn over with this project come on guys
well still that's a complicated thing
there are different backends and
different ways to connect for example
there are connection pools in the
database and so they are managed by the
database engine and there are lots of
details were not exposing so okay good
information on how to connect to a
database but does not actually perform
the connection the connection is
automatically performed
is automatically performed by functions
like relational database as well as by
database query function z' there is only
one basic identity such as entity value
okay now so in the workflow that you are
recommending to people they don't know
need to know about any of these things
here right not necessarily any
disconnect might be useful
I think it's an unbelievable hack to
have a property that masquerades
I think we could define database Connect
and database disconnect but they will
not be used very often
I think we should
you
could be any of the elements
you
you
um available in database reference of a
sock so you're gonna have to make a um
you know a pull request for yeah you're
gonna we're gonna add these database
connect database Chris connect um
you
you
can be any elements that can be supplied
um
as well as
you
there is an active connection to the
database both
okay so we got an ad database connect
database disconnect
you
so these things both refer to a two they
can they refer to relational database or
database reference which one or either
you
the best reference mean they typically
workin database reference but they can
also work directly on relational
database because of convenience
activates a connection
to the database dB
um the database DB can be specified
using database reference or relational
database okay
functions such as relational database
and entity value automatically our
connect to databases as needed
you
nothing else we should refer to here
anything else we should refer to there
please
what does it return
some failure right
okay
unless it should return I think it
should just return successful failure it
could return the name of the database
but I don't think that makes sense
Nauticus this connects deactivate should
we say deactivates a connection to the
database DB
I will mention the fact that if you are
already connected I doesn't fail and if
you are not connected disconnected does
not fail or sorry what do you what you
saying database disconnect if it
I mean I mean there are two
possibilities right either you're
connected or disconnected you're running
database disconnect okay so if you're
not already connected what happens yeah
so can you answer that question please
I I mean again I can say again a success
I would out was disconnected even if you
are maybe I wouldn't do that I would
return a failure that just says database
didn't wasn't connected I would I would
give positive feedback or mother it was
connected or not
where are we getting rid of two
different kind of success well that's
right exactly but see a success rate I
mean in both cases right okay
you
you
manually connect to comma disconnect
from a database
you
you
okay Carl on our live stream is asking
could do something with by with database
connect blah blah blah that auto closes
the connection at the end of the block
and saying it's a common metaphor in
other languages but not in ours well
there are things like block we can be
easily programmed by I mean I know the
question is how do you auto close the
connection do you do you should we have
a thing called database block that Auto
opens Auto closes that might be useful
if we can always guarantee that that it
closes well that's up to you by the way
that comma andraia will be incorrectly
formatted there I think it's something
we need to think about
I will not exclude it meaning sounds
like a nice idea okay all right we
should design it in in sync with let's
move on let's move on we were a lot to
cover
you
ah
database disconnect returns a success
object if it's successfully disconnected
or if
bass was not
I think we should just say this and we
should always return a failure object if
it either wasn't connected or the
database couldn't be found or any other
such problem make sense
yeah okay all right let's move on
oh my gosh there are no seals those here
how could that be
so database reference database connect
and then we also need to say entity
register right
maybe I don't know
that relevant to this might be entirely
I think entity store is more relevant
yeah okay and URL maybe
profound but those are probably relevant
somewhere okay all right relational
database were on - now
oh boy
I want to look at some of these other
ones as well strikes the schema
that mean extracts schema what does it
actually return
returns itself says it represents the
schema other thing is still on that one
it's supplied so please don't use client
file by the way I mean why are you
having to use that doesn't have a path
question hold on a second does this
respect dollar path when you give the
name of a file in this case does it
doesn't respect all apart to find the
file ok so the question is this if you
have the file wrapper then you cannot
choose example data because fire because
file doesn't confine file I think we
went through this before for interpreter
so we can we we can if you have if you
use if use just a bare string we do find
file automatically but not are not
within file because file is completely
inert and so it can't do can't have
weird evaluations politics okay do we
think the database reference should
allow a naked string or not I mean it
does right now
but you didn't document that no we
didn't because it's a convenience
because we weren't 100% sure that the
word gonna be no collisions between
various URL schemes and so on oh my gosh
so wait a minute so you're telling me in
here I'm not gonna I'm gonna future eyes
this but it's something that says of
quotes path right yeah we're even the
naked URL exactly so I understand it but
it could be a path it can be either a
URL or or another kind of path yeah okay
so you need to resolve
andraia I mean this is part of the to-do
list I mean we need to resolve it not
for version 12:01 happen like that makes
sense yes
okay basically these references it's
from constructor so you give it a file
path sorry dubby is a relational
database and then it becomes a big
complicated association with with the
database reference as the second
argument what sorry sorry sorry sorry
so in this case right so this is now
what an earth is that what is that error
okay so there's a database there are
it's pieces yeah whatever it's got in it
right okay so this is look know
represent
schema represents the the schema of the
database described by database reference
referenced by database reference okay
how do people know that this thing about
weights to something else
it doesn't evaluate to anything else to
device itself
look it evaluates to itself yeah but
it's if you look at the input form it's
not the same at all I don't care it's
still okay
but it doesn't scream it because it
doesn't return something different but
Steven I think it's important to explain
three volt then relational database all
what doesn't B's reference is performing
a side effect and Claude
okay so schema extracted from the
database represents schema
you
I mean if we had enough space the
correct thing to say would be that
relational database one is a nice
reference even ways to a
representational schema no because well
I see I see I see I see I see so the
right way to do this is
yeah okay so the thing is we have a
missing line here
you
you
represents
schema
represents schemas
schema information about a relational
database it's basic point right
fact that arguably should be the first
thing here
super this works I bet it won't work
I was wrong okay represent schema
information about a relational database
okay
gives the complete schema
you
of the database referenced by
gives the schema
give schemer information
tables related to the tables table I
okay
oh gosh look at this you've also got
these cases here
those are mostly a convenience I don't
care the documentation should be
specifying that right
I think we we should say this and then
we should fill in that that says
database reference later okay
boy I hope not every one of these pages
is this messy
you
we're not getting off to a good start
here
database
can be specified using
database reference dot dot URL dot dot
or file dot dot right
you
what is all this stuff what is this
we've never looked at this and there are
no seal shows here by the way what else
should we work should be reference here
entity list entity value what should be
reference here and did his store day
there is a reference obviously yeah okay
so Karla our livestream is concerned
about how the notebook front-end will
perform when there are hundreds of
columns in a database and a table rather
have we tried that
in this case here where this thing here
opens up have we done a test of this
where there's a huge number of columns
here oh we haven't done such tests yet
could you make sure that QA is aware of
the issue yeah yeah this is very
frustrating this is so messy
I mean how bad are these other things
going to be let's just look at one of
them just to get a sense of that so I
wrote the usage parts yes or no no I did
but at least here I added keywords and
Schultz's and in examples
no this is no good this is no good
listen one of the rules here is if you
read this line in the documentation
you've got to be able to know what this
is I mean for all I know this is a a
piece of you know that gives the
articulation of different kinds of
mammals right represents class sort of
according to the value of the property
okay foot of you know I don't know what
I don't know what this is right it has
to say entity yeah somewhere it has to
talk about the fact that it's an entity
it relates to entities
you
represents
class
I'm not even sure how to how to word
this who represents entity class
okay represents an entity class derived
from class by sorting according to those
values I think that's the correct way to
say it is that right calling us that's
right
you
you
sorts I don't know how we usually say
this sort successively
by well
so else the other properties I used as a
tiebreaker basically so
oh my we're already at time for this
meeting
fortunately I think I can I can go into
the time for the next one um
okay
okay well let's go back here so we're
clearly gonna have some time so there's
some rewording here that's gonna be
needed represent Santa Claus derived
from class
you
okay so this has to say that by default
is ascending
right
yes well it's it defaults the same way
that sort defaults and sort by okay how
is this multi thing like this relate to
how sort by works to sort by allow that
possibility of multiple tiebreaking
hands
yeah it does Aaron White's not properly
the prentices and use it it's not
documented but it does it with the cert
details note
that should probably be in the main
documentation I agree
you
you know what I'm gonna move this to a
second element to
and I have no idea how to put in a 7
plus can Andrea could you get somebody
to put in a 7 plus for that yes
you
maybe we should call this F spec
you
you
you
No how does this work so it applies so
there should be a case where it says F 1
F 2 comma P is that correct
I don't know because we were talking
about this at some point in IOT because
it's kind of dumped that there is only
one p for multiple apps so I don't even
know anything works here so can we
determine that please but at least we've
documented this case here um
you
you
you
by successively using the values of the
properties
you
I
and it lets prop 1 should say prop I
shouldn't it
I think that's not correctly formatted
there I don't think that worked
correctly and rare that's another thing
for you to chase um now you know this
this sort buys this specification thing
of ascending descending probably should
be supported also by sort by I brought
that up like one year ago and well we've
also got reversed sort by haven't we
yeah that's also global I understand but
but sorting up oh boy
ok a good I'll D topic let's cover that
they're ok
no this isn't correct when it sorts
according to the prop I
well by the way do you also support prop
arrow
yes you do but you don't tell anybody
that
you don't say prop arrow spec here right
no come on
so you should either is what you're
saying is that we should first see
proper respect and then just say props
back in the following one no I don't
think so I think we should do this okay
class prop arrow spec um sorts well if
this is going to be sorts according to
prop in the order specified
okay so here
you
you
maybe this one and the previous one can
be merged into one because it can be
this or without specified order now
let's not do that
oh yeah I see what you're saying I see
what you're saying
you
you
let's say that
yes
okay all right let's go back over here
table level properties
is this really consistent to say foreign
primarykey the list of columns yes so
the profit premier he's only always only
one even though it might reference
multiple columns I mean a key is not a
column a key might be multiple columns
and so primary key can contain multiple
columns and each foreign key know
there's title there it says foreign key
in sell foreign keys here okay
gives a list of Association to the
following elements
wait a minute what are the name what's
the name of each gives a list of
associations okay
okay so if I go over here to our hand a
little example
I was it
you
yeah okay so you are saying if I say
okay tables so I say percent one sub
tables okay now I say percent one sub
employees
, primary key employee number okay so
now I say
okay so if I say foreign keys
you
you
you
you
okay but this is okay this is within one
schema these foreign keys are pointing
off to those places fair enough
you
you
wait a minute no we cannot call this
back-end type we should just call it
type mean I wouldn't do that
well why it's wrong a tiff type native
type is fine
you
you
don't you want to qualify these a little
bit more I mean if you see something
that says okay so if I say
here
okay so I'm gonna give a column here I
meant I've got a table employees I
didn't even ask for columns
okay
so let's say extension
so here
you
you
what that - nothing Oh where's extension
in place of cars yeah and it should be
lowercase I think okay now what should
this do I mean we could make this return
association but the wait I don't see why
we shouldn't make that return an
association I think it should the
problem is that if that returns an
association then we end up with we can
never have a column called columns so we
end up with reserved words that's why I
yeah I say okay well then maybe we
should have an awl here I think that
works
inside it
Oh fantastic then we should just
document it shouldn't we
you
I think it works at all levels
okay um
so wilmut so then we say then this would
be what would I say here an association
Association containing all of column
level properties
right yeah
it works also at table level properties
so under foreign keys you can add
another line no here right if that was
all yeah yeah yeah right that's what you
mean
you
you
shouldn't it work at the level of
top level
cuz it's not very interesting that maybe
there's but okay
alright fine
so that is a native type there that
correct yeah I mean it's why are we not
using something more like the type
specifier structure of the compiler so
maybe the cover should speak to this I
wasn't there the impression that this
was gonna be like some horrifying string
like bar chart and we need to include
body information we we haven't done that
yet we are not exposing the low-level
type that should this be called native
type I mean it's not quite no no the
native type is something like bar charts
and again what should this be called
kind and this is this is our type yes
this is our internal type so string but
but it's not our type it's not our type
because our type would be something like
somebody's switched on their the our
type would be something like type
specifier of blah blah blah right then
done document it go document what
what we have read now is begging type
because we will need to transform it
into this type switch if I am
we didn't do it well I mean maybe we
should quote are you going to expose
varchar' 10 because I think you should
yeah we need to do this right now so
maybe no but the verbatim string that
comes out of the database we can expose
like from our chart and people will want
on it yeah that one normalization which
is not really normalized anyway right so
you're saying we've got a partial
normalization here that turns it into
string comma 10 um right and we don't
include the low-level type information
we could I'm suggesting native type the
native type of the data stored in the
column which would be varchar' quotes of
our chart an in this case right now what
you're saying is there are two levels of
cooking of that raw information one is
the string comma 10 level right so if I
say
um probably all of these are email are
um just strings at this point right so
for example let's find out how long a
name I'm allowed to have
50 characters Wow okay
first name the same length can I be like
like gum you know one of those
well it's multiple first names one of
those European royalty type things
or just Brazilian soccer player okay
well I don't even know what lost name
means and that who knows um okay yeah
but I agree that the thing that we
should be exposing it's not our
half-baked normalization fine and then
you're right that there is like yet
another level which is more at the
entity level which is some stuff that
will never be stored in the database
like quantity will buy a native type or
Bagan type if we are not sure about it
no no Roberto native type is just fine
it's just not this it's varchar' 50 or
whatever it is right but we also need
that right now for the implementation
into the object but let's not document
what okay let's let's call native type
varchar 50 and we hit back and type not
implemented sorry not documented as our
internal version that's well let's call
it let's call it um how should we call
it normalized type okay sorry if if in
database evidence were created back end
then beg and type should be virtual and
stuff no that should be native type look
back end type is the type of back-end we
are using the word Bagon into database
donatus eventually that's the the
complaint the backend is not an
objective if you say back and type that
means SQLite right type of the backend I
think for the sake of generating
something in this association I would
recommend that you call it normalized
type you have native type which is you
know varchar' 20 or whatever it is can
we can we keep normalized type on
document yes don't document the street
but I agree don't document it but I'm
saying that it will come out when you
say all you know it want it want because
only the things that are okay alright
terrific terrific then that's good then
then you just put it in but don't
documents it and it don't document it
don't disk or JIT it's
okay um okay question from Mohammed on
the livestream will there be a way to
get generated SQL code that is sent to
the backend that is a good question I
was wondering that myself and we do have
the functionalities that we just don't
have the hooking entity value to pull it
out I think we should yeah I I think
like third are doing 20g value that's
real string but there's also a
complimentary thing that would be useful
once the SQL string is there because
just a raw result that you get back you
might need to transform in certain ways
into the shape that you need sorry I'm
trying to you're saying that the
modifier shouldn't be
okay you're saying entity value is the
thing that actually goes in and does the
SQL query okay can you show me what some
of these SQL strings look like how do
you get the SQL string right now
we have a function which is not has not
been completely polished which i think
is called
okay I'll check what what the name is
it's undocumented or why the second okay
but is it is it a single because entity
value is a resolver right and arguably
this as SQL string thing should also be
a resolver
but somehow it needs to get currently is
a holder holding wraparound entity value
which our health rather than talking
about okay what is it yeah once
um
let's see I mean I'm kind of thinking
you
I would hate to use I mean SQL requests
could be a symbolic wrapper like a HTTP
request soon I'm saying other words with
all of our infrastructure there's no
reason why you can't send in a raw SQL
request is that correct or is that crazy
we have the infrastructure through that
it's I mean I think it requires more
careful design because in general you
don't wanna it's considered bad form to
have a single string that already
contains the parameters so it should be
more like a template with an association
that fills in the parameters I say so
I mean it's not something that I would
want to rush into trial point oh yeah
okay fine look I suggest what we do is
provide a developer level function that
extracts the SQL string so what what is
the and we should document it as a
developer level function
I'm making sense
in the developer context or if you want
you could put it in the function
repository actually that's that's fine
too
the results another way to do it I was
completely different
my dick is still useful as developer
function it's like you know each time a
query is executed you have a function
that can lock it and so if you do if you
set this variable to echo or to print in
your current session basically printing
all the SQL query that are executed well
I think what it should be look I think
what we should do is put in the function
repository a function that is called
something like
you know if we have a thing called SQL
echo
right and then it's a wrapper around
entity value and so on an SQL echo would
echo the SQL queries as they are
executed
so SQL echo would be a controlled
evaluation of anything that contains and
then
there should probably be called S
Kalikow block but why
because echo is not a controlled
evaluation from anything it just takes
something necklace it this is no no no
no no no it doesn't it theme oh I say
how do I get it I see I understand okay
yeah you're right
and this would be SQL query string so I
think you should implement those two
things as function repository functions
okay makes sense I don't think they'll
be very useful and they will be you know
they're in the function repository so
they are what they are they're not
guaranteed to stay quite the same and so
on okay
um but I think that's yeah definitely
useful I mean I would even argue that
those are well let's put them in the
function repository see what see what
happens with them okay God got the names
and things yes I can delete this file
yeah okay so all right time
go to the rest of this which is nice ah
let's see what else should we mention
here on the relational database should
be point people to public entity store
we already did anything else here
okay I mean this clearly should point to
database link but that's a different
thing yeah
okay all right look I think
have to rap here um let me just take a
look let me look at my schedule for a
second
oh boy
yeah um
well I think that the example you know I
would I would try to write this weed out
with less repetition and will go much
faster and they just use its messages
okay if but I suggest we bad I mean then
I would I think this one is the one the
only one that you had already looked at
because we changed oh no no no no this
is not the one we looked at it was the
entity class that you looked at
unfiltered okay but this I think should
just say I mean this has to be
you
okay but you gotta say we are not saying
what F is I mean if people to pure
function or down values there it's not
my work
is that right yeah
but what about for a regular in-memory
entity store
I think I mean in that case you would
wrap your you can always wrap your pure
function or down values enhance function
but enter some strands kind of peculiar
semantics so I wouldn't want to use a
naked down value there even for an O an
in-memory entity store yeah I mean you
can make a trivial wrap around any
function in a memory and historic surely
filter identity class wants to reference
sampled entity clause
I don't know the Select mention take
but this seems relevant in this world to
do that
all right
um okay I think that's as far as we're
gonna get today let's hope that there
are no further I don't think they're
going to be other design changes we've
gone through the design of these
functions quite carefully agreed
Mia hope so all ooh I need to discuss is
the type system and there is relevance
when we start the next discussion about
writing to database and so on the type
system you said right that's a totally
different issue
I mean and
yeah I mean basically before you even
say anything about that it really has
just got to align with the type system
we're using for the compiler so go learn
about that if you don't know about it do
you already know about it I know
something about it and I'm not convinced
that that's gonna allow goodness sake
Steven that's very different than we
already discussed that in the plane so
for example just to give an example the
type system for the compiler right now
it doesn't allow anything like
Association and internally we do support
it through the system for what for the
compiler doesn't support Association for
example well but it's obviously code
through doesn't it
I don't know well mostly it's got to
because even the other thing is that
yeah the other thing is that the tie
specification for the core database is
gonna somewhat look closer to the one in
interpreter because you're gonna have
things like a date represented as a unix
time that's the kind of types we want
for the high-level stuff okay you need
to talk to Tom and the people working on
the compiler sure and this argument that
the compiler doesn't support
associations is there is a better
argument really and that is that the
compiler that tom works on and what we
are doing are solving very very
different problems because we are
compiling to a language of the same
level of expressiveness as whorfin
language itself while compiler is
compiling to a strictly lower level
language and that makes a huge
difference
excuse me I mean there as you've just
pointed out like in Wolfram language we
can express you know a quantity of maths
and kilograms or something right yes we
can't do that in SQL we can that's not
so yeah of course that's the point the
point is that this looks much more like
the type system of interpreter in that
it's all serializing and deserializing
specifically what I would think it is I
think it is it's more like what we have
in data drop that's what
I would look at that drop his
interpreter I understand but what what
what you're saying okay that one of the
points is in interpreter okay so the
database is the sort of unwashed
external thing that is just a string
which interpreter maps to a mass
quantity for example for example yeah
it's it's because you will we will also
need to know how to turn and washed
wanti into an unwashed number so
remember also sterilizer so there is
also very practical reason why you want
to do it very similar to interpreter you
want to automatically create a former
there is a data into the database for
example and and in order to do that the
DEP system needs to be consistent with
that still we can always ever our way to
transfer from one type to the other but
yeah I mean in a dry application you you
should be allowed to specify like a
person type and then you can
automatically create a table you can
automatically create a form - it's the
data and the specification should be
saying okay a couple of comments on the
live stream from call why why aren't we
having database query echo because
actually that that's even wrong I mean
these are look this is just function
repository stuff
yeah I mean actually question for Tony
for the sparkle query stuff is there
also a an echo or bowl
string there
so sparkle query and update strings are
fully supported in import and export so
you can go both ways so wait a minute
you take a query you take one of the
query objects and you just do an import
on it yes boy here first Symbolics
barcode very or update string you pass
it to export string to see how the
string would look like okay so why can't
we do that for the database for the
relational database case
because we are working at a much higher
level that's the that's probably like
Tania's introduced I don't know how many
new symbols for dealing with low-level
Sparkle stuff we haven't and and as fuel
works basically just transparently as
any other entity so that's so we don't
have dedicated heads to do this stuff
all right I mean if we if we start
designing a way to expose the database
functionalities yeah we can discuss
about this stuff yeah okay well okay so
that's so it's a different thing because
those databases you're saying there's a
direct symbolic representation of the
query so the way it works is like this
basically
right now we have entities compiled to
an intermediate language that kind of
looks like the sparkle one that Tony is
exposed and that language is going to be
the common target when we want to expose
for example query through database query
language
sorry dataset query language then it's
also going to compile to that common
thing so this intermediate layer that is
closer to SQL than it is to entities
it's it's currently only internal it's
not really something I mean it's really
similar to what we are doing with
entities we basically have one ad that
is called instead of being an entity
field thread class we have thought of
base field thread and so on and so forth
there is really a one-to-one
correspondence between entity functions
and database functions and then of
course we have other stuff what are
these database functions used for other
than your internal plantation only so
far on the orange it's basically our
completion target but what we are
capable doing l-value
I mean is our idea and I don't want to
talk about this a great length right now
but is our idea for database updating to
essentially have an l-value structure
that is similar to I mean we do have an
l-value mechanism for entity store don't
we yeah but I think that we need to
dress this up in some way because if you
start doing things entity by entity it's
going to be terrible for performance
to me City and so on so we need to
really think closely on how to do locks
and stuff like that you don't want to
use no end map and set to do this stuff
yeah unfortunately all right well great
um okay
to be continued thanks guys and I think
we won't need another unfortunately I
thought this was gonna be our last
version 12 database meeting that I think
we will need one more um and yeah there
it is but if you can make the changes
I'll push these changes back if you know
you know the obvious cosmetic changes
that will be helpful and don't forget to
do the updates that you need and Andrea
don't forget the formatting things yeah
I opened five bugs during this meeting
so okay we have notes okay sounds good
thanks also folks on livestream okay bye
bye